i know you just celebrated a big
birthday camila and yet you're the one
gifting us fans with the announcement of
the album i'm so excited what a true
gift um how was it celebrating oh my god
i mean
it was i went really really hard
everybody went really hard it was very
fun it was a 2000s themed uh birthday
party so everybody came dressed up and
like you know two thousand vibes all the
throwbacks we're playing um
i'm really living the lesson in bambam
which is keep dancing because i i dance
a lot
[Music]
[Music]
i'm so excited that uh we have some new
music coming because i got to tell you
selfishly camila i have run don't go yet
into the ground
[Applause]
[Music]
talk to me about bam bam obviously it's
the first new song of the year and it's
finally out
[Music]
it wasn't like reuniting with ed for
this track you know he is like
my
dream feature collaborator and so when i
sent him the song
and
he was like oh i love it let's
definitely do this i just felt like this
is too good to be true he's gonna change
his mind
you know and he didn't and he's been so
excited about it throughout we literally
you know he sent like that beginning
kind of chord progression through
instagram dms and we were kind of
writing and brainstorming back and forth
on instagram and then he had a morning
and aft half an afternoon off in l.a and
we wrote his verse in my verse and it
was just fun to brainstorm with him and
to like write these lyrics with him you
just reminded me that you probably had
to dm him because he doesn't have a real
phone right so you couldn't like text
him
couldn't text him it was all instagram
he was like instagram dm or email and i
was like you know dm is closer closer to
text than right email email i'll get
back to you in three weeks by that time
you won't want to be on the song anymore
so
you guys co-wrote this song so tell me
about the writing process a little bit
what was inspiring you as you were
writing this song and the story that you
wanted to tell well i i started writing
this song with my collaborators um
a few months back and uh so we had this
kind of
chorus idea uh
about just kind of like what it's been
like
in my late teens and early 20s kind of
kind of falling in it in and out of love
and ups and downs of that
and also reminding
myself uh as my mom has told me
in real life many times that
that's life you're on the ground crying
in the bathroom floor and then you'll
have feelings for another person again
and then you'll be crying on the
bathroom floor again
and
that is kind of like the cycles of of
change like things just change you never
know what's around the corner
um i sent him that idea and
he was like i love it i feel like the
first verse could be different
um so we went in and we kind of wrote we
kind of brainstormed these lyrics and
wrote it again and uh i think what
really gets us you know
turns us on as songwriters is
the details and like really showing in
those little details of life how things
change you hated the ocean but you're
surfing now
[Music]
i said i love you for life but i just
sold that
house we were kids at the start i guess
we're grown-ups now
and um
that felt really exciting to us so we
kind of ran with that idea can you talk
about like who or what in your life has
kind of helped you through those times
when you needed to get back on your feet
um
one uh my therapist
two
yes uh my friends and my family
hence
familia
um i think that it's i feel like i have
more and more resources i get as i get
older so
now
whereas before i would be like oh my god
i don't know like what to do i'm just
like running around like
kind of freaking out all the time like
when are these kind of negative feelings
going to go away
as i get older i found more and more
resources so
for example like meditation and
talking to a therapist also talking to
my friends like literally
just being like guys i'm feeling this
and this fear i'm feeling sad about this
like really being open with people
going for walks like so many different
things like i feel like that's kind of
the key to getting older is like
those feelings are gonna come and i
think you just gather
more and more tools to cope with them in
like house and also your music i mean
how lucky are you that you have
songwriting as a tool to kind of work
through those emotions too i imagine
it's pretty cathartic
totally totally i mean for example like
this song bambam and like psycho freak
for me my process is really cathartic
because
it's me
kind of singing anything that i think
about and feel into a microphone
and i do like seven
takes of that i do that for like 25
minutes and then
me and my collaborators talk about it
and we
you know are like oh you said this that
was really cool we brainstorm we fill it
in and then that becomes a song but like
the beginning of it is really just this
word vomit and so
it is very cathartic so that's a big
definitely big tool for me and i i miss
it when i
am not in the studio you've been working
on this next labor of love familia for a
really long time and you posted that
this album is your whole effing heart
what else can you tease about this
record we're about to get from you
um i feel like
you know a lot of people have told me
like
this feels different than your other
albums and
in the sense that it feels more grounded
it feels more honest and
not that in my other albums i haven't
like tried to be honest but i think that
in this one there was just so much like
there was kind of no barrier of like
pressure or anxiety or
you know it was just very like
unfiltered like it was just like
literally whatever i was feeling that
day
and i think that comes through in the
music you know um
it's just like very like raw like
everything about it i feel like just
true we love that you collaborated with
ed what about another bestie taylor
swift have you guys talked about when is
going to be the right time for you guys
to get on a track together
and what would that sound like do you
think
i mean i would
love that i feel like she is
i would learn so much from writing with
her because i just feel like as a
lyricist
she just like can run laps around
everybody
um
and me too i mean like i i
just am so
yeah inspired by her um
as a songwriter i would love to
i would love to get in the studio with
her um i feel like it would just be like
a master class yeah i would love that
whenever she's down i'm down
[Music]
you